hi this is presh talwicker in this video
i'm going to explain the mathematical
formula for the body mass index also
known as the bmi
bmi is a way to estimate body fat from
the two variables of weight and height
one way is to divide your weight in
kilograms by your height in meters and
square it
the equivalent formula in pounds and
inches is to take your weight and pounds
multiplied by 703
and divided by your height in inches
squared
so while the bmi gets talked about a lot
it's actually a relatively simple
formula
that's a ratio of your weight and height
so let's do an example of someone who
weighs 200 pounds and has a height of 5
feet 10 inches
we convert that to 70 inches and the bmi
will be 200 times 703 divided by 70
squared
this is 28.7
to make sense of this number we look at
the different ranges below 18 is
considered underweight 18.5 to 24.9 is
considered normal weight
25 to 29.9 is overweight and above 30 is
considered the definition for obesity
so a bmi of 28.7
is in the range of overweight
we can similarly look at bmi by the
following table
you can look and locate where your
height and weight are and it'll tell you
which range you're in so a person who is
200 pounds and 5 feet 10 would be about
where the black dot is which is in the
range of being overweight
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon for exclusive rewards
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalkar and you can
get my books listed on my website